>> So let's look at a concrete example, where
the hypothesis space is the set of intervals. So the
inputs that we are trying to learn about are
just single numbers on the real line. And the hypothesis
space is this set of functions that return true
for all the things that are between a and b,
and this is parameterized by a and b. So
how many different hypotheses are there in our class here?
>> At least 2.
>> Sure. How about how many are there in the class?
>> There's an infinite number of them.
>> That's right. So, so this is one of these situations
where it's going to be really helpful to apply the notion
of VC dimension if we think we'd like to be able
to learn from a finite set of data. Which, you know, generally
we like that. So how do we figure out what the
VC dimension is? We want to know, what is the largest set
of inputs that we can label in all possible ways, using
hypotheses from H. Alright, so, I want you to figure that out.
Figure out the, the largest, the size of the
largest set that we can shatter, that we can label
in all possible ways using these hypotheses. And then just,
you know, write it as an integer in this box.
>> Cool.